[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Paris Ashlyn etus a lecture and
Hellenic studies and political science
his current research interests include
social movements populism Greek politics
and methods of text analysis today we'll
talk with Professor ashlynn itís about
populism and social movements
welcome professor esslyn Edith thank you
very much good to be here yes so
populism let's define that as a term
right so it's I should have a ready
answer for that and I and I do but
there's a you have to know that there's
a long controversy over the meaning of
the term so I define it as a type of
anti-establishment discourse in the name
of the people right which means that
which means that there's a politician or
a social movement that has this rhetoric
that idolizes the people and claims that
the elites or some form of elite is
responsible for the grievances of the
people and the the legitimizing force
behind the argument is a notion of or
the value of popular sovereignty right
so the people feel that in every society
its members should be the ones making
taking decisions and on how they govern
themselves right and when this element
of popular sovereignty is somehow
undermined by a powerful force out there
we the so-called elite then they have
they justified too you know
we bail against what is going on and
claim back sovereignty into their own
hands right that doesn't leave so much
space for normative considerations yet
on whether this is a good thing or bad
thing which is you know the way most
people would approach the topic
I see that as a second level question
and we can of course discuss it but in
terms of as we say seizing the object
and identifying if you want to put it
simply who is a populist and who is not
a populist I tend to look at what they
say at what the discourse of the
movement or the party is and identify
whether they employ this distinction
between people and elites as the
dominant theme right there are of course
other views out there others would
associate populism with specific
policies for instance economic policies
this is the dominant view amongst
economists for instance others would see
populism as a as having to do with
undermining liberal democracy and it's
institutions others see it as a strategy
that you know there are savvy
politicians out there they know this
works and they use it cynically in order
to attract voters so there's a
constellation of different views out
there yes one of them at the group of
thought where which I subscribe to is
the one that sees popular as a discourse
okay so let me ask you this what drew
you to be interested in populism sure
you are Greek yes yes and I know you've
looked at populism in Greece I mean is
that part of it or is it something else
great question so back in 2011 when I
started my PhD we had this social
movement in Greece remember Greece was
in the midst of the crisis in 2011 right
and everybody was out in the streets
protesting against the bailout
agreements and you know austerity and so
on and so forth so we had this movement
that did mobilize this feeling of you
know we are the people here and some
guys up there who we do not like are
trying to defraud us of the of our
sovereignty
right and my academic mentor back then
so it would be a great idea to study
populism
in the form of a social movement which
was because this is what we were
experiencing but
right so it was political developments
that actually led me to the topic and I
haven't regretted it to be honest
because I managed to study populism both
as a form of party politics but also at
the grassroots and I'm actually I have
actually specialized in the grassroots
aspect because not many there are many
scholars who have employed the term
populist in social movement studies and
that's the ground I'm trying to break
how do you look at populism at that
level I mean what are you looking at
Facebook you know what kinds of things
social media is a good way of course
populist didn't begin you know in the
era of social media we had populist
social movements before that so you
usually follow the paper trail of the
movement could be manifestos of the
movement it could be interviews with its
activists could be flyers or banners
right in general you try to figure out
the collective identity of the movement
who's whose we in the moon if you ask
them who are you you know why you are
why are you out there in the street as a
group what what is this group all about
and who you are how you against so
what's your grievance and who do you
direct it against and you get answers
along the lines of you know we are the
people and we are protesting against
bankers or businessmen or could be
academics of course you know the elite
group has different types of
connotations around the world and we're
protesting against you know the
inordinate power over us then you're you
know you you're on track to be able to
label that a populist movement right the
specific grievances differ the specific
elites against whom these grievances are
directed also differ for instance I
would claim that both the Tea Party was
a populist movement here in the States
again during the crisis and Occupy Wall
Street right some people have trouble
associating the label with both
movements
that has to do of course with you know
you're normally of understanding of the
whole concept I try to be as as
objective as I can and just employ my
work as a tool of identification and
then I work away from there I see I'm
curious to know your thoughts about how
populism develops in a country we can
talk about Greece of course I'm also
interested in your thoughts about the
United States you've been in the United
States here at Yale for the past three
years or so with the new president
coming into power I'm interested in your
thoughts about particularly the United
States and populism and and is it
growing in your opinion because it from
where I'm sitting it seems to be right
so for many academics the u.s. is one of
the most fascinating cases when it comes
to populism and it has been since its
founding more or less many would tell
you that the u.s. was founded as a
populist republic up to a point because
the notion of popular sovereignty is
very strong in this country right the
fact that it rebelled against monarchy
right has infused the population with
values of you know we the people that
are very strong and this creates a and
an undercurrent of potential
mobilization throughout the decades so
it's it's the same with every other
country out there in the world where its
population feels entitled to claim that
power should be in their hands right so
whenever whenever certain part of the
population feels that this is not
happening for X or Y reason it might be
right that might be wrong right so if
they feel that somebody is trying to
defraud them of the power there's always
an element of opportunity for political
and pronouced mobilize a feeling right
it could be a leader as in the case of
Donald Trump who portrays himself as an
outsider of the political system that
helps
right if you're part of the elite of
you're part of the establishment it's
difficult to mobilize these feelings but
in that instance it's curious to me
because while he claims to be an
outsider of politics he still is a very
wealthy white man which is really
outside of the norm for the majority of
this country so that fascinates me yeah
he's not the first to do that we've had
Berlusconi in the past in Italy it was a
similar case we've had cases in Central
Europe so it doesn't matter who you are
where you come from what matters is how
you how you manage to sell that right so
Trump manages to sell that outsider
persona of his with another important
pillar especially for American politics
which is being a successful businessman
because he knows how things actually
work out there he has made money so he
can prove that he knows how things work
which is you know what's contrasts with
how politicians understand the world
they know because they know nothing
about how businesses actually work and
I'm the one who will you know manage to
produce growth for this country right so
even though he's very wealthy he has
managed to use that as an element of his
outsider status rather than being a
disadvantage for him so this has to do
with the big emotions of constructivism
in politics right it's not only about
who you actually are what actually your
policies are political communication
plays a large part in the whole story so
I guess he was successful in selling a
story look what right right
I'm curious also your thoughts on again
how populism develops in countries and I
think do you think that fear plays a
role in how populism develops and
particularly with what is going on
pretty much all around the world with
immigration and having you know new
people come into your country that you
might not be comfortable with how do you
see that playing right so xenophobia and
populism
or nationalism yeah that's a very
difficult topic there's some conflation
between the terms here and it depends on
which part of the world you're coming
from your experience with populism in
power in politics in general more or
less conditions the way you see the term
so if you're a Latin American xenophobia
or nativism has nothing to do with
populism populist leaders in Latin
America Latin America have to
additionally been left wing and nativism
played no part in their political
success okay if you come from Europe
Western Europe particularly most
populist parties tend to be on the right
or on the radical right and immigration
especially in the past thirty years has
become an important issue
so populism is no phobia are two
completely different things they don't
have to be together in order for a
populist politician to emerge but of
course you have many cases of
politicians who both who employ both
populism on the one hand and xenophobia
on the other so they manage to trigger
different values out there in the
population with different attitudes one
of them could be the notion that you
know they're losing power as citizens
the other one could be that part of that
is the fact that our country is allowing
all these olymic illegal immigrants to
come in and take our jobs for instance
right there are two different aspects so
there's a lot of talk about populism
rising lately but I would say that
populism is a small part of what is
going on most of it especially in the
West has to do with nativism rather than
populism rising to the forefront of
politics and sometimes it's it's it's
good to be precise in how we use its
terms because if we assign everything to
populism then there might be another
danger out there that's even more
important and we're losing sight of it
right so I wouldn't be ready to concede
nativism to populism you can have
populist movements or parties that have
nothing to do with nativism but of
course it's a large part of what's going
on out there right right okay and do you
think populism will continue to grow
throughout the world or do you think
perhaps not what are your thoughts there
right that's a great question so
populism comes in in waves throughout
history and what before I'll stop you
there and why why do you think that is
because the people cannot be mobilized
every every year to feel like they're
losing power right there has to be a
trigger there has to be a an agent who
successfully constructs a story you know
we tend to look at successful cases of
populist politician but there are so
many unsuccessful instances right
politicians are trying to mobilize this
feeling every every month or every in
every campaign but they don't always
manage to do that right oh they or they
do that with little success so the big
story is when somebody manages to use
populism as a dominant theme in their
campaign right and this has cannot
happen in every campaign
it can happen every 20 years or 30 years
or 15 years has to do with the economy
and how they comb is fraying right why
do these people feel weak or do they
feel fear right is it because there has
been a Great Recession remember the Tea
Party and Occupy Wall Street they both
emerged during the Great Recession so
for some people there is this notion of
the losers of globalization or
industrialization in the past right so
whenever there's a part of the
population that for X or Y reasons feels
that they're not legitimate there are
not seen as legitimate members of the of
the country of the society that they
helped build then they will be more or
less a vulnerable to the populist
argument
so this is why it keeps coming up every
now and then I think it's always gonna
keep coming up as a famous scholar of
populist market can often put it in the
past populism is kind of like a shadow
of democracy right so it helps the
church keep going right because if we if
we take away this notion of popular
sovereignty from the whole notion of
democracy then we're left with a very
dry concept which is very technocratic
and it won't be able to mobilize people
in feeling that democracy is a good
thing
so this majoritarian element of
democracy of We the People has to be
there at some point right and of course
in in dangerous times it can be
mobilized by people who will lead
societies down dark paths in other times
it can be mobilized for good reasons can
you cite an example of a good reason
right it's a great topic so you can't
imagine that there is a country out
there where elites have indeed managed
to win power and the people are
suffering right right plenty of them so
in in those cases a populist movement
would be legitimized but it would would
be a legitimate way to try and tell
citizens that they need to do something
about it
specific cases well it all has to do I
guess your ideological leanings right so
if you if you ask a trump voter today he
will tell you that Trump's populism was
a good thing right in the past we've had
left wing populism in the States as well
we've had Huey Long and in the 30s right
we've had even the People's Party with
the populist party back in the 1890s you
could see that as a left-wing movement
you've had McGovern in the 70s
many people claim he was a Prairie
populist as they put it right and now
you have Bernie Sanders right for many
the left Bernie Sanders is a healthy
populist element in our political system
right so the fact that you just claimed
that we need to do something against
those elites in Wall Street or wherever
it's not necessarily a bad thing
the your judgment should have to do with
the actual policy that the pie or the
movement emphasizes as a solution to the
problem and to be honest I think that
most politicians out there employ a
little bit of populism in the Disco's
and I should have mentioned that at
first I don't see populism as a
black-and-white thing it's not like
you're either a populist or you're not a
populist and my work is based on that
and it's it's a graduated concept so all
politicians employ populism right the
question is whether some of them turn
that into the dominant theme which would
allow us to call them populist easily as
a shortcut at least but the the fact is
that populism exists both with good
politicians and bad politicians okay
well this has been fascinating thank you
for clarifying the term populism because
I think it is thrown around and I don't
think a lot of people truly understand
what it means so thank you for that and
sharing being here with us today and
sharing your work thank you very much
okay for more information about
Professor Ashlyn etus and his research
please visit our website at macmillan
report yale.edu be sure to join us again
for another episode of the Macmillan
report made possible through funding
from the Whitney and Betty Macmillan
Center for International and area
studies at Yale
you
[Music]